the song that made you most famous i
believe was girls just want to have fun
right was that the big one was now girls
just want to have fun would have gone by
the wayside had there not been time
after time right after it
girls just want to have fun you were
interested
number two and you introduced that song
with with your whole wrestling
connection wwf at the time because at
the time howard radio wasn't playing
girls just want to have fun they said we
had a note from the best
program director in the country that
said they would talk to us and tell us
you know how we could adjust my career
because
girls just want to have fun would never
be played on top 40 and it's not album
radio because they sing too high so you
you wisely now i understand this wwf
connection wolf
loved wrestling and it was his idea and
he said i have another idea i'm going to
put you on wwe
and you play girls just want to have fun
on the wwe tonight saturday morning and
saturday night he said you'd get three
hits in a weekend he found an
alternative way to distribute the music
not using the radio yeah and it paid off
promotion and we had fun and so the
record starts to sell from the wwf fans
they go hey we want to get a copy of
this girls just want to have fun well
that wound up on e.t
as a news item cindy also gets some help
from a former professional wrestler i
captain lou alvaro the maker of
champions predict that cinderella will
be the greatest entertainer of all time
and all of a sudden what we were doing
was bleeding over to all these different
mediums and we were having a riot so we
said okay
now we know what we're doing right and
so it was on mtv it was on news it was i
didn't realize the wrestling had such an
effect on your career
because i was like why is she doing that
i was already aware of you as an artist
i was like why is she doing all that
wrestling but that makes sense to me
well i stayed you thought outside the
box yeah but i stayed because
it was the one place that dave wolf and
i
could still work together as equals not
as
just he's your manager is your favorite
song that you do the true colors
to me that's my favorite one you do you
know i like sally's pigeons i like um
i feel that is your most raw performance
oh it's naked yeah naked and murray
turned that song down true colors
was a song that was pitched to anne
murray right and
my friend gregory had passed away
and at that age when you have friends
you don't think
you think you're gonna
live forever i guess and be old and sip
and mint juleps not that i like what
that tastes like but the idea of it at
the pink hotel somewhere you know right
and uh it didn't happen so
we were very sad
you know we had the funeral i was doing
the song and all of a sudden
i stripped the song down because it was
you know it was pitch for anne murray so
it had santa like country western gospel
right i just was working with peter wood
at the time then he um
i said just make the chords that we use
so he kind of
did different voicings and
i stripped it down and just sang with
the keyboard and then when i went back
in to the studio
lenny was working with me and i said you
know i just want the voice to be
like
when someone's driving in a car
you hear it in your ear like a whisper
and everything in the song has to call
to your soul
so i put a drum sound
that was kind of an archaic um like an
old old
sound like an ancient drum right
called to the soul and then
kind of whisper in the ear and it was a
healing song so i thought that that
would be the best way
to heal people on a medium that does not
have that kind of music on it ever right
and so i mean girls just want to have
fun kind of healed people too and it
didn't have
that kind of sound on it ever either so
i took a chance and of course the
promotion guys are like sin where's the
music come on you're killing me you know
right but it couldn't take a lot of
music because once it did when the lyric
is that
um
honest and deep and sentimental you
strip it down yeah you don't put more
sentimentality on top of it or oversing
it because then it becomes sticky and
cheesy and smoky
you